the incredible amount of love and
support and warmth means so much to me
nikkietutorials in tears over the
outpouring of love and support after
coming out as transgender when I was
younger I was born in the wrong body
which means that I am transgender the 25
year old makeup artist revealed the news
in a video called I'm coming out that
she uploaded to her YouTube channel on
Monday now fans fellow beauty bloggers
and celebrities are praising her for her
bravery and honesty sharing this with
you today is first of all oh my god this
feels so liberating ariana grande
commented heart emojis and clouds on
instagram under Nicki's post announcing
the video was live Lena Dunham shared a
few emojis as well while Maddie Ziegler
wrote so so amazing
wasn't expecting them Amber Rose chimed
in so proud and happy for you
I just thank you thank you I'm gonna
take today to just read everything take
it all in
although Nicki's had a flood of support
her decision to come out wasn't on her
terms she admits in the video that she
didn't plan on releasing the private
information to the public just yet but
she was inevitably forced to I have been
blackmailed and people that wanted to
leak my story to the press it is vile
and it is gross and I know you are
watching this this one's for you I hope
you can stick nice on it over the years
Nicki's channel has focused on the power
of makeup but she told her fans that
it's time to explore it the power of me
Nicki said that she hopes being open
with her subscribers inspires others to
do the same this world needs us
[Music]